Ya sabemos un montón acerca de los exponentes,
si nos encontramos por ahí a un 4 a la 3,
ya sabemos que esto es igual a, pues tomar el 4
y multiplicarlo 3 veces,
o sea 4 por 4, por 4,
que bueno, hay dos formas
de encontrar este 4 a la 3.
Una es ésta y la otra es tomar un 1
y multiplicar por 4, tres veces,
pero a final de cuentas, nos queda exactamente lo mismo que es igual a 4 por 4 = 16 por 4 = 64.
También sabemos exactamente que hacer
cuando nos encontramos con exponentes negativos,
por ejemplo 4 a la -3.
Nosotros sabemos que este menos,
que en el otro vídeo lo coloreábamos de morado,
lo que hace este menos es que tomemos el recíproco, ya sea que tomemos 1entre,
y luego esta expresión pero, sin el menos en el exponente o sea 4 a la 3
ó,
que tomemos el recíproco de este número 4
y luego eso lo elevemos a la tercera potencia,
¿Ok? Que tengamos 1 entre 4
y eso lo elevemos a la tercera potencia,
pero bueno de cualquier forma tomemos el camino
que tomemos para encontrar 4 a la -3,
siempre va a ser igual a 1 entre 64.
Ahora lo que vamos a hacer
es algo un poco más interesante,
que es tomar exponentes racionales ¿ok?
Exponentes que son fracciones.
Así es que vamos a pensar en qué significa
4 elevado a la potencia 1/2.
Así es que ya sabes, ponle pausa,
por lo menos intenta adivinar qué significa esto ¿ok?
Y ya después ya le pones play,
Y bueno, resulta que la definición matemática que...
bueno, en realidad todo el mundo usa
es que 4 elevado a la fracción 1/2
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 4
¿Ok? Esa es una definición mundialmente aceptada
¿y por qué lo definimos así?
Pues por que si lo definimos así,
tiene un montón de propiedades muy elegantes,
y a la hora de manipular todos los exponentes
y hacer todas las cuentas con ellos,
resulta muy conveniente.
Por cierto, ¿a qué nos referimos con raíz cuadrada de 4?
Nos referimos simplemente a algún número,
que si lo multiplicamos por sí mismo 2 veces,
nos queda lo de adentro de el radical que es este símbolo de aquí, que en este caso es 4.
A ver, seguramente ya sabes
cuál es la raíz cuadrada de 4.
A ver, ¿cuál es ese número que si lo multiplicamos
por si mismo 2 veces nos queda 4?
Pues ese número es simplemente 2,
¿ok? Porque 2 por 2, que lo denotamos
por 2 al cuadrado es igual a 4.
Entonces la raíz cuadrada de 4 es 2
porque 2 al cuadrado es 4.
Bueno, vamos a ver otros ejemplos,
por ejemplo tomemos por aquí 9 y elevémoslo a la 1/2.
Esto es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 9,
pero la raíz cuadrada de 9 es igual a...
a ver, un número que si lo multiplicamos
por sí mismo 2 veces nos dé 9.
Pues eso simplemente es un 3,
porque 3 por 3 es 9, ok,
que podemos a escribirlo por aquí,
3 al cuadrado que es igual a 3 por 3,
es igual a 9.
Entonces raíz de 9 es igual a 3
y la raíz de 9
es igual a 9 elevado a la 1/2.
Entonces ¿tú qué opinas?
¿Se empieza a notar el patrón?
¿o hacemos más ejemplos?
Bueno, de todas formas,
vamos a hacer más ejemplos.
Tomamos por aquí 25
y lo elevamos a la potencia 1/2,
y entonces, esto de aquí
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 25,
así es que estamos buscando un número
que si lo multiplicamos por sí mismo 2 veces
nos quede 25 y ese número obviamente es 5,
porque 5 al cuadrado,
que es igual a 5 por 5 es igual a 25.
¿Ok?
Si se nota más o menos el patrón, ¿no?
O sea tenemos aquí 9 a la 1/2
y 3 al cuadrado.
Bueno,
ahora yo quiero que me digas,
¿cuánto crees que vale 8 elevado a la 1/3?
Pues lo más natural es pensar que 8
elevado a la 1/3 es igual a la raíz cúbica de 8
y si pensaste eso estás completamente en lo correcto.
Y nosotros ya sabemos cuál es la raíz cúbica de 8 ¿no?
Por que la raíz cúbica de 8,
es igual a justo ese número que si lo multiplicamos
por sí mismo 3 veces nos da igual a 8,
y ya sabemos cuál ese número, ¿no?
O sea si tomamos 2
y lo multiplicamos por sí mismo 3 veces
lo que obtenemos es 8.
Entonces la raíz cúbica de 8 es igual a 2.
¿Ok? Y 2 por 2, por 2, es igual a 2 a la 3
y otra vez aquí estamos notando cierto patrón.
Pero bueno sigamos con esto de los ejemplos,
ahora tuvimos
64 elevado a la 1/3, a ver,
¿a cuánto es igual?
Pues obviamente es la raíz cúbica de 64.
Pero la raíz cúbica de 64 es justo ese número
que si lo multiplicamos por sí mismo 3 veces nos da 64.
Y por aquí acabamos de ver que
4 elevado a la 3 es igual a 64.
Entonces 64 a la 1/3 es igual a 4.
Ahora este asunto,
se puede generalizar para cualquier fracción
de la forma 1 entre y algún entero,
¿ok? podemos tener por ejemplo,
32 elevado a la potencia 1/5
y aquí lo que tenemos que hacer es pensar,
en qué número,
si lo multiplicamos por sí mismo 5 veces nos da 32,
pero creo que ya sabemos cuál es ese número, ¿no?
Porque tenemos que 32 es igual a
2 por 2, por 2, por 2, por 2,
2  por 2 = 4 por 2 = 8 por 2 = 16 por 2 = 32
y qué curioso aquí tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5...
de estos 2 que se están multiplicando.
Entonces 32 elevado a la 1/5 es igual a 2
y bueno, la otra forma de escribir
este hecho de la vida real,
es poner que 2 elevado a la 5 es igual a 32.